we can't say what's up - nobody can tap
them this is not its life on life turns
mansun be okay trust me it's real ow
this has meant to be the tournament to
go so be it the beautiful day today will
you add Joe good man New York is [ __ ]
murder they killing everybody in New
York manatee and you know how to hood is
my taint really taking it serious
no not even a little bit they that's why
yo Mike they on the corner light like
you know y'all vacation I'm not y'all my
brothers like an ox cross is doing that
I start crossing soon they're gonna call
soon they gonna call soon he's getting
real out here the lives of man they
don't this house meant to be the
tournament ago so be it it's a beautiful
day today
you ain't lying Mike us that I share
that same view was like I feel like God
you sat us down there's almost like when
we went to jail was like God status down
he ain't made everybody appreciated
everything we got you know and slowed it
up and make everybody preciate your
family you know somebody go crazy being
with a family for one week then they
don't deserve that family B you need to
enjoy the time hey listen man I'm very
grateful I've been locked up a lot I
know it's like not to have ten I'm it's
very grateful to be with somebody you
know it had some kind of communication
man who they cut down on the internet
now we really be fun I know we really be
in trouble
and you see all these guys they went
home in quarantine for one week and they
like yo I can't do this I can't do this
I'm right Y always fight I'm feeling
like there's a lot of rats going around
here like him they got locked up they
tell on anybody to get out of jail alone
is it the hell of a thing they got here
in China the divorce rate went up yeah
when the divorce rate went up soon
this happened they can floor that again
living I was Adam all day they need some
time your I've been fortunate man
because my wife on a normal circumstance
she know how to get on my nerves was she
been real good with just her own a virus
I'm lucky a [ __ ] man so I am Mike man I
love you bro what's going on listen man
I'm very grateful to be talking to you
but this is the weird time in our life
but it's a great time to be alive at
this time
weird time in our life are you
absolutely right about that man it's a
great time to be alive and I feel like
man what we gonna do when we get out of
this man how're we gonna feel when we
get out of this man this is all feel so
good when just you appreciate going to a
restaurant I don't and gathering the
people again I miss gathering with a lot
to people man that's something else that
you know we affectionate man we like to
say it's up to everybody gap from hog um
like that's crazy
right now like we can't say what's up to
nobody you can't DAP them it's not it's
life on life's terms man it's gonna be
okay trust me God not gardening create
us to suffer we create suffering human
beings we create suffering and I believe
that Mike I believe a lot of we do is uh
and believe it or not it might sound
corny and nuttin or something but you
know ever since everybody stopped flying
everybody stopped going in the water
you know house working ignoring my
brother nori and he lives on the beach
he's like yo man I never seen a water
more clearer I never I never seen you
know the sky looks cleaner everything it
looks like the book the earth is
breathing now rather than us just moving
like we've been moving like polluting
the earth it's a possibility the
possibility though the world's been here
longer than us so I'm sure it's smarter
than we are
that's a fact that's a fact man so Mike
what do you been doing with your time
you've been home with the fam look I'm
with the family before this happened
with the family I'm selling cannabis I'm
doing moving
movie series coming ontogeny car rolling
with the punches about me after retiring
from box I'm into the cannabis business
I'm selling I'm losing money I'm
wondering when there is just some
beautiful stuff I'm glad to be able to
like I wouldn't even believe 20 years
ago I'd be alive doing this stuff so
this is just yeah yeah that's that's
that's one of the questions for my show
like I didn't I didn't think Mike Tyson
or Fat Joe would get to this age no not
a look at it wasn't cool getting if they
all of our friend died young and Gloria
sister you never think about dying old
listen 50 years old houses old you know
Emmanuel 1550 was old yo 50 was
prehistoric I don't once I asked my
uncle when I was little I was like your
whole-- are you the man said 40 I walked
up I was like oh I was like oh my god
and now we a we don't want to die but we
made it and now we're walking around -
oh geez and uh we playing this game
called lights out yes a real-life
electro they know what I wanted to say -
before we got up i watch the show
growing up if I'm gonna watch the
sunrise I love me some don't care
different me different you know what
happened to me I was in Wow and it you
know sometimes the kids be so smart that
you you you don't we don't understand
them no we don't no way we can
understand that we don't understand them
and then they turn out being so smart I
think this guy this guy did a four-year
college in two years like in school he's
the smartest [ __ ] the world
common sense the [ __ ] crazy to
me man
I might rise when someone tell me I knew
he was special it's a good guy yo Mike
where you the man bro I love you so
much more thank you so much Joe I am
Mike Tyson baby I did Mike Tyson don't
worry won laughter whoo take care